I have to mention
that in his latest tirade in which he
goes full conspiracy
Donald Trump now doesn't even look
orange
it's like burnt sienna for those who
used to watch Bob Ross I can only
describe this as the color of a sunset
very late in the evening I don't know
why Trump is doing this to himself but
he is now
uh a bizarre color
and he is raising the Deep state in his
latest full conspiracy rant Trump is now
announcing if indeed he becomes the next
president of the United States he will
create a truth commission this now does
sound like 1984. you know for for so
long now I've been saying everybody says
this is orwellian It's really hoxland
this is really more out of Brave New
World than it is out of 1984.
the truth commission Trump wants is more
orwellian here's Trump's latest promise
uh
I don't know folks this is scary stuff
to expose the hoaxes and abuses of power
that have been tearing our country apart
we will establish a Truth and
Reconciliation Commission wow to
declassify and publish all documents on
deep State spying censorship and
Corruption and there are plenty of them
right fifth we will launch a major
Crackdown on government leakers who
collude with the fake news to
deliberately we false narratives Now
understand that's a Crackdown on
whistleblowers Trump calls them false
leakers but in many of these cases we're
talking about whistleblowers and Trump
clearly wants to go after not only the
Whistleblower but the media Outlets that
publish the stuff as well the
journalists as well completely attacking
overtly journalism as an institution to
subvert our government and our democracy
when possible we will press criminal
charges there you go as many as one
hundred thousand government positions
could be moved out and I mean
immediately of Washington to places
filled with Patriots who love America
and yeah
um so first of all it's like sure sure
you're gonna do that right after your
new health care plan and Mexico is going
to pay for it as well right so so of
course with all of these things it's
less about what Trump will do but what
Trump would like to do or is willing to
admit that he would try to do this would
be endlessly chilling so corrosive to
many of the fundamental institutions of
American democracy and in a sense it's
the same old song and dance this is the
real grievance politics when we've
talked before the right says the left
wants to censor it's the right that's
doing a lot of censoring the right says
the left is going to try to steal an
election well the right tried to steal
steal the election and of course the
Wright loves to say the left is all
about grievances grievances over racism
and grievances over this that the other
thing the right is running at this point
the height the epitome of grievance
politics but it's based on grievances
that are imaginary completely imaginary
grievances so Trump looks to absolutely
terrible he sounds terrible he is now
regularly releasing these videos often
at midnight or even later they don't
make any sense they're scary and if
you're wondering like why is Trump doing
this stuff when it seems like he's about
to get arrested the New York Times
article we talked about earlier says
that Trump's totally disconnected from
the reality of his legal problems Trump
seems to think that it's all going to be
great he wants to be handcuffed he
thinks it's going to be great for his
campaign and that he's going to win and
then he's going to put in place a truth
commission would be really scary if he
were likely to be able to do it but it's
up to us to make sure that he's not able
to that clip I just played and others
from today you can find them on our
Instagram you can find them on our
YouTube channel you'll be able to find
them on our Tick Tock or or anywhere
else that we publish content